- Well I wanna get to that
but you bring up a very
fascinating point to me,
your liberal friends.
You know your dyed
in the wool liberal
or your mainstream liberal,
they have made what we're
dealing with possible.
- Yep.
- Because they've
never stood up against it.
And now they're being threatened
by it like everybody else.
Some of them see it,
Bill Maher and some
of these other people.
Naomi Wolf, although she's not
a liberal, she's a radical.
But nonetheless they see it.
Even Glenn Greenwald
sees it, he's a leftist.
People are saying go, uh-oh.
Yeah uh-oh.
You remember Stalin
went after Trotsky.
These people are not nice.
I mean Mao wiped out
all of his lieutenants,
this is the way it goes.
(calm music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and joining
me today is a lawyer,
a bestselling author and a
broadcasting legend, Mark Levin.
Finally, welcome to
The Rubin Report.
- David, it's a great
honor to be with you.
You know how much I admire
you, thanks for having me.
- Well I'm thrilled
to have you here.
What do you consider
yourself first?
Because you've written what,
like 800 bestselling books.
I mean New York
Times number one,
they couldn't have
been happy about that.
I mean what really
are you sort of first?
- You know, my
attitude about this is
I use every platform
I possibly can
to advance the cause of
liberty and constitutionalism
and unalienable rights
since I was a kid.
So I moved into radio first
which I enjoy the most.
I love to write because
it really gives me time
to think about things.
You know to really focus,
think things through.
It's not a fast pace
like radio and so forth
and of course
television I like too.
Because a lot of
people are very visual.
Unfortunately they
have to look at this,
this punum as we
say but nonetheless,
I try to use all these formats
to do exactly the same
thing in a different way
and I think our country
is in desperate need
of as many Paul Reveres and
Thomas Paines as possible.
So that's my attitude.
- Yeah.
- And I don't really know.
- Well you are
one of the Paul Reveres
and I wanna get into
some of the stuff that
you've been ahead on
because you've been
kind of warning
about what's happening forever.
But let's just back up for a sec
because I realized this morning
as I was doing a
little research,
I actually don't know that
much about your childhood
and I sense, you
strike me as sort of,
you were conservative at five.
Is that possible, is that right?
- Well it started
in a log cabin.
No.
- Yeah, with the guy
behind you I suspect.
- I think, that yeah.
No that's correct.
Look, here's the thing.
I never liked authority,
that's a funny thing.
I didn't like classrooms,
I didn't like how
strict they were.
I was beyond it, I was ready
to do my own thing as a kid.
I was ready to read my
own books, check history.
We didn't have the internet
and so forth and I,
that's exactly what I did.
And I didn't understand why
I had to do stupid things
just because that was
the regiment that I had
and so I think that had
sort of an intellectual
or philosophical effect
on me unwittingly
and as I got older I
really did distrust
what people were telling me.
Not that I was
paranoid or anything,
it was like I
wanted to check it.
I wanted to make
sure I agreed with it
and sometimes I'd say,
"Well what is that all about?
"I don't agree with that.
"What about this?"
And my general philosophy
is live and let live.
That's pretty much
my general philosophy
and get out of my face.
That's pretty much it.
And it's gotten a little bit
more complicated since then
but I think I was a
libertarian at a very young age
and more of a
libertarian conservative
and then I kind of
coined this phrase
or made it public again which
is constitutional conservative
20 years ago I said.
Because I was referring to
the Constitution all the time.
But yeah we would,
around the dinner table,
around the breakfast table.
There were two brothers
and my parents.
We were very talkative,
we would debate the issues
and I'll tell you something
Dave, none of us were liberals.
Even though we're all Jewish
and so none of us were liberals.
My father passed away, my
mother who passed away.
My father told me he voted
for Goldwater in 1964.
Now how many Jewish
people do you know
who voted for Goldwater in 1964?
And I said to him,
"Dad, why did you do that?"
And he said and I'll quote him,
"I knew all the bullshit they
were saying about Goldwater
"couldn't be true
so I voted for him."
And that was kind of my
attitude at a young age
and you know, and then
you add meat to the bone.
You start reading
philosophy and history
which I can't tell you
how many books I've read.
Economics and that sort of thing
and you develop a way of
living and a way of thinking.
- Yeah, let's dive a
little deeper on that
'cause you mentioned
sort of libertarian
to conservative to
Constitutional conservative.
What was it, as you know I've
sort of brought the phrase
classical liberal back and
that was what my book was about
and people always say to me,
"Well Dave, is there any
really meaningful distinction
"between classical
liberal and libertarian?"
So actually, let
me start with that.
Do you see any
meaningful distinction
or have the labels and words
all become sort of
muddled in modern times?
- Well they can be.
But they're in the right area.
Other words, not
right philosophical.
- Yeah.
- In the correct area.
You know I've always,
libertarian conservative,
conservative libertarian.
It's like Scalia and Thomas.
They both wrote opinions,
sometimes they would agree,
sometimes they would disagree.
But the way they approached
the issue was what is key.
What is it that
drives your thinking?
What are your principles
behind your thinking?
And so, I was once asked.
I think it was by Ben
as a matter on his show.
He said, "When you
interpret the Constitution,
"do you do it from a
libertarian point of view,
"or a conservative point of
view or how do you approach it?"
I said,
"Well libertarianism and
conservatism are philosophies.
"Interpreting the Constitution
"is interpreting
the Constitution."
That is, you're not supposed
to bring a philosophy to it.
You're supposed to try and
discern what the framers meant
and what the words
meant at the time.
So I don't get into this,
am I a conservative,
liberal, libertarian
when I interpret the
Constitution, it's
the Constitution.
So why do I call myself a
Constitutional conservative?
I have many libertarian beliefs.
But I call myself a
Constitutional conservative
because of the thinking and
the arguments and so forth
that people understand
that went behind the
Constitution itself.
Debates oh well we
don't want a mob,
we don't want a monarchy,
we don't want these things.
We don't want direct democracy,
we don't want factions.
What do we want,
we want a republic.
And they developed
the most fascinating
and I hope lasting republic
that man has ever created.
So are there differences?
Well of course
there're differences.
Libertarians fight with
conservatives all the time.
Guys like Hayek and Nietzsche,
they had no stomach
for conservatives.
The Austrian school.
On the other hand,
Milton Friedman did.
He's one of my great heroes
and so we're gonna argue
over libertarian versus
conservative, I'm fine.
We're gonna argue over
Americanism versus Marxism,
that's a whole nother.
- I think we're gonna be okay
on whatever the
marginal libertarian,
conservative differences are.
- Right.
- So let's put that aside.
But you know,
every way that you just
answered that question.
What sort of sat beneath it was
you have great reverence
for the founding documents
for the founders, for our
history and it seems to me
we live in a time
where that is just,
you actually said hope.
That was meaning that you hope
that these things
will still matter.
But we in essence
live in a time where
we're erasing all of that at
a rapidly increasing pace.
- Yeah and I'll get
into this a little bit,
I've been thinking
about this too.
We are and why is that?
Why is it that the world
we're told in America now
has begun 1619 and not 1776.
Critical race theory,
critical immigration theory.
The attack on capitalism
with the degrowth movement,
the climate change movement.
All these things, what are they,
why do they kind
of just spring up
in the last 20, 30 years and
especially our focus this year
and last year?
And the reason is, and
I'm gonna use the word.
These are Marxist-based
ideologies.
If people understand Karl Marx,
they understand his writings,
they understand his background.
Now I've studied him
very very thoroughly
for a project I'm working
on, he was a journalist.
People don't even know
he was a journalist.
He had many articles that
appeared in the New York Sun.
He was a classical liberal
for a period of time
and then something
happened, he saw things
and he abandoned it and then
he developed his ideology
really based on Rousseau
and Hegel and those guys
and he just moved it
towards materialism
and he just, he was an angry
man, he was a poor man.
He always relied on
his lawyer father
and his friend Engels
to subsidize him.
And I think, and by the
way, people don't realize.
For 30, 40 years after he
died nobody cared about Marx
except American progressives
who were fixated with him
but all that said, I'm
of the attitude that
with the early
progressives, Dewey, Wilson,
Crowley, all these guys and
more, they said basically,
"We need to change
education in America.
"It's not enough to teach
mathematics and history
"and English without
a social construct,
"without an understanding
"and putting in a
cultural perspective."
And that's what they did.
They fundamentally
altered public education
which became bigger and bigger
and then they
altered colleges and,
you know back then as I recall
about 6% of the population
graduated from college.
Today it's about 34, 35%.
And so they felt as elites
and so-called intellectuals,
that is where they could
make the biggest change
and they have.
They have fundamentally
altered the way
at least half the country
looks at this country
and as you know, Marx
wanted a clean slate.
So our history is
to be attacked,
our history is to be degraded,
our history is to be rejected.
So whereas somebody
like me and you,
we look at our history, an
ancient history and all history
in order to try and figure
out, but what is mankind about?
Where should we be?
Are we doing the right things?
Does this make
sense, they don't.
So ANTIFA, Black Lives
Matter, leftists period,
they attack American history,
they reject what
the framers did.
I'm going on here
a little bit Dave
but you know it's interesting.
- No, no no I'm with you.
Well you're talking
about the slow march
through the institutions.
So what do you do then?
- Yeah.
- So if we're at that
strange place now
and you know, 35% of
these, of the kids
that now go to college.
So now you've got 35% as
opposed to 6%, what do you say,
that was just a couple
decades ago in essence.
Well that's an awful lot
of brainwashed people
coming out of these schools.
- Yeah.
- What do you do in
an age of social media
and in an age of a culture war?
- We have to begin to
use the left's tactics
against the left.
I believe this very, I
never used to believe this.
I used to preach free
market capitalism,
I still believe in it.
All these other things and
they're very, very important.
But tactically, we're
gonna have to get active.
We're gonna have to do things
we've never done before.
Because Marxism is a
constant revolution.
Conservatism or a
Constitutional conservatism
is a stand in place.
And so they're
always on the move
and we're always on defense if
we're doing anything at all.
I look at it with the
Democrat and Republican Party.
It's not a precise parallel
but the Democrat Party
is always breaking windows.
Republican Party is always
sitting in rocking chairs,
just watching it.
And so this has to change.
Now I can't control
the Republican Party
and I think that's why a
lot of people like Trump
because wittingly or not
he would break windows
when they would break windows.
Like wow there's a guy,
finally who's fighting
for these things.
But also, I think more and more
of us in our individual lives,
we're gonna have to
become activists.
I don't mean violent
activists, I mean activists.
In everyday things that we do,
where we choose to buy things.
When we talk to
neighbors, form groups
to go to school boards, do
all these sorts of things.
Start pressuring
our legislatures
where we have
friendly legislatures
to pass laws like they do in
Florida to address big tech.
We need to be on our fence,
we need to bring litigation.
We need to throw as
much against them
as they throw against us and
do everything we possibly can.
I mean the nation was
founded by men who took
a very activist
role in their lives.
They were pushed to a point
and of course the difference
between the Marxists
that we deal with now and us is
they wanna destroy our society.
- Yeah.
- You know that's interesting.
The French Revolution, they
wanted to destroy their society.
The Russian Revolution,
the Communist, the Chinese,
they all wanted to
destroy their system.
The American Revolution
wanted to preserve our society
and change the government.
What's happening here
is we're up against
street Marxists or mobs or
whatever you wanna call them
that wanna destroy our society
and are demeaning our
society as the CRT folks.
You know we're a white
dominant society.
So everything related to
it is bigoted and racist
which is so absurd and
I just think we need to
stand up and say enough,
we need to push back.
Everybody has a different
role in this life.
Some people are electricians,
some are bus drivers.
Some do what we do and so forth
but all of us in some
role in our life,
whether it's our
purchasing power,
whether it's school board
meetings, churches, synagogue.
We've gotta speak up,
we've gotta be heard
and we've got to organize.
- That's what I
keep telling people.
Nobody's coming to
save us except us.
- You're right.
- That really is it.
How worried are you
though that with,
you mentioned big tech,
that with the acceleration
of information,
that by the time say
we get to the midterms,
the amount of destruction
that these guys
will be able to do, whether
it's packing the courts,
changing the electoral
college, immigration.
I mean the litany of things
that I know you're worried about
that it will be too late.
That in some ways that
the founding documents
won't even be able
to stand up to it
because there is a wash coming
that seems oddly unstoppable.
- It's a great point.
A lot of firewalls in the
Constitution have been breached.
It's been a long time coming,
I've written about it over
the course of 20 years or so.
They've been breached by the
courts, they've been breached.
And so comity.
You know, C-O-M-I-T-Y.
That sort of thing
used to exist you know?
Run an election, you
lose, all right I lost.
Now there's another
election coming.
Now the game is with,
I lost an election,
I never intend to lose
an election again.
And your question
is do we have time?
I don't know, but we need to
fight like hell 'cause I can't,
I don't know what's gonna
happen in two years, five years
and six, I know what'll happen
if they win and we lose,
it's gonna be a totally
different country
and people are gonna
be sending their kids
through indoctrination mills
and all kinds of terrible things
are gonna happen in this country
where people probably still
don't believe it's possible.
It's possible,
it's happening and that's
one of the key things.
People need to understand
this isn't theory,
this is reality.
It is here and now,
this is going on.
This is repression
that's taking place.
People, it can
happen in America.
It can happen anywhere.
And you know, we had
these firewalls in place.
Many of them have been breached.
Many of them are controlled
by the wrong people
and so that's the reality
and we have to push back and
do everything we possibly can.
- Is the fundamental problem
that the firewalls only work
if we can sort of agree
that the rules are the rules
and now we're fighting
something that doesn't agree
that there are rules or
that the rules were set up
by evil, patriarchal,
racist, you know,
whatever you wanna call it.
- You hit the nail on the head.
Freedom without virtue
doesn't, it's not freedom
and that was exactly
what the founders said.
You can't just have freedom,
you have to have people who
are gonna follow the rules.
You have to have people
who have integrity.
You have to have people who
don't wanna burn down the place.
So you have an
election, fair election.
You win, you lose,
okay next election.
It's not, I'm gonna change all
the rules to make sure I win
and if you don't agree with
me you're a Jim Crow racist.
So the Democrats have decided
to take on the posture
and the substance of the
most radical elements
within the party.
And that's why you sit.
You know you watch
this Chauvin case
and you watch the riots and
everything and you watch
either the silence
of the Democrats.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- Or the celebratory
tone of the Democrats
and even though Black
Lives Matter and ANTIFA
aren't official wings
of the Democratic Party,
in many ways they're
the useful idiots
of the Democratic
Party and vice versa.
They feed off of each other.
The Democrats need
to stir the pot.
They want their
base to be angry,
they want their base to
coalesce around them.
You wanna use the opportunity
to change the country.
Whether it's the voting system,
whether it's the immigration
system, whatever it is.
And that's exactly
what they're doing.
And so when you hear what
Biden said a couple of days ago
after the verdict.
You know, "This shows
America's systemically racist."
I'm going, "Who the hell
are you talking to?"
What do you mean America's
systemically racist?
I'm not Chauvin,
I don't even know
what the hell you're
talking about.
You don't even know what
you're talking about.
40 years ago you were
a white supremist,
now today you're
telling us we're all.
He's a very evil man who's
always been about Joe Biden
and so on.
Then I watch Kamala Harris
get out there and say
the nation's
systemically racist.
I don't need to tell you
but to underscore the point,
there are millions of people
trying to get into this country.
- Yep.
- They're not
coming from Sweden.
They're not coming from Norway.
They're coming from
Central and South America.
They're coming from Africa,
they're coming
from the Far East,
they're coming from Asia.
These are minorities,
these are people of color.
By the millions they wanna
come into the United States
because we're
systemically racist?
I mean how absurd is
this whole debate?
- And Mark, none of them
are leaving this country.
It's a very confusing
thing where,
let's back up to
Biden for a second.
- Yeah.
- Because I had,
I still have a couple
friends who are liberals
that will still talk to me.
Mostly privately, they won't
talk to me publicly anymore
but a lot of them kept saying,
"Don't worry Dave,
after the election.
"Don't worry, Biden
is the firewall.
"They didn't go crazy Bernie,
"they didn't go crazy
Elizabeth Warren.
"Biden will stand up
against this stuff
"and now that Trump is
gone it will be easier
"for us good liberals
to fight the wokesters."
Well, in the few months
since this has all happened
I have watched these people
fold like a wet paper bag.
Did you have any illusions
that Biden might stand up
to some of this stuff or
did you just fully believe
that he was gonna go down
this route no matter what?
- Well I wanna get to
that but you bring up
a very fascinating point to
me, your liberal friends.
You know your dyed
in the wool liberal
or your mainstream liberal,
they have made what we're
dealing with possible.
- Yep.
- Because they've never
stood up against it.
And now they're being threatened
by it like everybody else.
Some of them see it,
Bill Maher and some
of these other people.
Naomi Wolf although she's not
a liberal, she's a radical.
But nonetheless they see it.
Even Glenn Greenwald
sees it, he's a leftist.
People are saying go, uh-oh.
Yeah, uh-oh.
You remember Stalin
went after Trotsky.
These people are not nice.
I mean Mao wiped out
all of his lieutenants,
this is the way it goes.
- Right they're not just
coming for Levin anymore.
- The French, that's correct.
- Now they're
looking at me, yeah.
- The French Revolution,
Robespierre he went
after everybody and
then he get the ax.
So the Revolution is
a nasty piece of work.
But we still don't
have the liberals.
They're either completely silent
or they just think
this is another cycle
we're going through
and so forth.
We'll all come out
of it just fine.
We need the liberals,
we need to unite.
We need to have people
who aren't them,
the Marxists who are trying
to destroy this country.
We may have disputes
over this little issue
or that little issue.
But if you love this country,
put the damn disputes aside.
We've gotta unite against this.
They are attacking every
aspect of the Bill of Rights,
our unalienable rights.
They are attacking businesses,
they're attacking minorities,
they're attacking
private property rights,
our free speech,
they're attacking
freedom of assembly.
Go down that list and it's
happening very, very fast
as you point out.
As for Biden.
- Wait can we stay,
can we just stay on that?
- Yeah, yeah.
- For just one second.
- Yeah.
- Because I'm
fascinated by this.
- Yeah.
- And as you know
I wrote a book
defending liberalism
but do you think that
there is a fundamental flaw
in liberalism that has stopped
these people from doing that?
Because that's the
uncomfortable conclusion
that I've come to at this point.
- To me, the flaw is.
Look, what you did
was very brave.
But you can live with yourself.
You said you know
what, I'm over here
but there's too much weird
stuff going on over here.
I don't agree with all
this, it's too weak.
We're losing this,
we're losing that.
I gotta move over to some extent
with these other
guys who get it.
I don't have to agree
with them on everything
but fundamentally,
they're civil,
I'm a civil libertarian.
- Yeah.
I believe in civil right, I
believe in individual liberty.
That's what I believe in.
The left believes in group
this, group that, even liberals.
We don't even see the
ACLU anywhere anymore.
Where the hell is the ACLU?
- Nope,
they're in on this now.
- I mean they're no.
- It's that we don't see them.
- They're in on it.
- They're in on it, yeah.
- And that's the thing.
So to me, what
liberals, traditional
liberals have done is
they've made it easier for the
hard left, the Marxist left.
They've helped pave
the way for them
and I think some of them don't
know what to do about it.
It's like well I don't
really wanna say that
the 40 years I've lived are
flushed down the toilet.
- That's it.
- On the other hand,
these other guys are
kind of ugly over here.
I don't know whether I
wanna join them you know?
And they're gonna
get rolled over
with the rest of us if
they don't stand up.
- It's odd, I haven't
found you people that scary
since I've joined you.
Nobody's that, they
always warned me
that Levin, Shapiro, Glenn
Beck, these are scary people.
Prager, very scary.
And yet.
- We're very easy.
- Yeah.
- We really are.
Yeah.
- No, do you think that
there is something connected
to belief that plays
a role in all of this?
I've sensed that with
my liberal friends
that come from a more purely
secular position on this
that their underbelly
is just too soft.
It's too sort of, we
accept everything so yeah,
we'll kind of go down
the road to hell with ya.
- Whether you get it from faith
or get it from somewhere else,
if you don't believe
in existential truths
and if you don't believe
in look, the golden rule.
The 10 Commandments, is there
a problem with the golden rule
and the 10 Commandments,
I don't think so.
Well those are the fundamentals.
Really, when you write them
down that's the fundamental.
You look at the Declaration
of Independence,
the reason why that
document is so incredible,
these men, they knew about
Judeo-Christian history,
many of them were
practicing Christians.
These men knew all
about the enlightenment,
the Reformation,
they studied it.
They studied Aristotle and
Cicero and you name it.
They knew, they were
well-educated men
and they put together this
Declaration of Independence.
They put everything on the line.
Everything on the line.
So look at that Declaration
of Independence.
Abraham Lincoln cited the
Declaration over and over
and over again
during the Civil War.
Now one of the things he said,
that a country's founders who
could write such a document
and leave it to their progeny
to fix this issue of slavery
were magnificent men.
And Abraham Lincoln did
more for Black people
than any other human being
ever in the United
States, ever, ever.
He loved this country, he
embraced the Constitution.
He was disgusted by Taney,
the Chief Justice of the
Supreme Court in his ruling,
in the Dred Scott case
but he always defended
the Constitution,
defended the founders,
making the point,
we wouldn't even be
here as a country
but for what these men did.
Flaws and all and they told us,
we can't fix this
issue of slavery
but our children and
grandchildren are gonna have to
because endowed with what?
Endowed with our rights.
- Inalienable.
- Unalienable rights,
that applies to every
single human being
on the face of the earth.
You know, when Jefferson
originally drafted
the Declaration,
there were five drafts.
He put a provision in there
that the British were
forcing slavery on the colony
which they were.
They abolished slavery but
they were extremely active
in the slave trade.
They were making money off it.
We had borders that were very
porous, we couldn't really
and they kept moving slaves,
selling slaves into
the United States
and one of the things that
Jefferson had said in there.
Even though he'd been
a slave owner he said,
this is one of the reasons.
And some of the Southern
states blocked it.
So you know something like that.
Embrace the Declaration.
They knew they couldn't
resolve the slavery issue,
they eventually did
resolve the slavery issue.
Like no other country on
the face of the earth.
No other country had a
civil war over slavery,
we did.
- Yep, yep.
- And when you listen
to people today,
it's as if none of
this ever happened.
But what I was gonna say is
this about Biden real fast.
- Yeah, sure.
- We can come back.
I'm getting older so
my memory pops around.
- You're doing just
fine, you're doing fine.
- Biden has always been
a nasty piece of work.
He came into the Senate,
he coddled up to James
Eastland and John Stennis.
Two old, Southern,
racist segregationists.
Eastland was even
a plantation owner
who said the most horrific
things about Black people.
Biden coddled up to these guys.
Biden opposed busing.
A lot of people opposed
busing, including Black people
that didn't want their
kids bused 25 miles
in each direction.
But Biden's language
was different.
He used the language
of the racists
and he talked about he
didn't want his kids
going into these
jungles and so forth.
He would.
- The racial jungle,
that's what he said yeah.
- The racial jungle.
He would say the kinds of things
that the racists would say.
And then later he
was tough on crime.
"You know, I was the
author of the crime bill."
He used to say, of course
he doesn't say it anymore.
I don't have a big problem with
that crime bill by the way.
Crime went way down but
that's a whole nother story.
- Yeah.
- Then he shifts
his position because he
sees that's not popular.
And now, you know he wants to
be bigger than FDR and Obama
and Johnson.
And that's all he cares about.
Biden is a very dumb
guy, he's an egomaniac,
he's always wanted to be bigger
than really his capabilities.
That's why he plagiarized
as a young man,
that's why he stole
words from Robert Kennedy
and Neil Kinnock
when he was running.
Back then we actually
had standards,
so that knocked him out of
the running for President.
- Yeah people don't know
that, he plagiarized
and that actually
got him to step down
from the Democratic primary.
- That's right.
- I think like 88 or so?
- Today it would
be like who cares.
- Yeah.
- So he's always been that way
but he's always been for Biden
and that's what
you're seeing now.
Biden didn't give any indication
that he was gonna be to
the left of Bernie Sanders.
Every piece of
radical legislation,
radical executive
order, radical policy
that he can put in place,
he's putting in place bar none.
- Yeah.
- Bar none.
I feel like we're getting
hit in 1000 directions here
with this guy.
- Right, well.
- And so.
- Well that's the bizarre.
- Yeah it's not
really ideological.
It is a personality flaw.
- But do you think he's
driving it at this point?
That's the part that
I can't figure out.
It's like I don't think
he really believes
in all of this stuff.
I also think he has
cognitive problems
and a whole slew of other
things but it's like who,
this is what everyone
asks me all the time.
Who's the driver of all of
this radical leftist stuff?
It's not obviously not 47
years in government Biden.
Is it Obama?
Like who's behind the thing
do you think at this point?
- You know what, I
think it's all that.
I think he's, look at his staff.
Look at the people
throughout the government.
It's like pick the craziest
bastard you possibly can
for every one of
these positions.
- Yeah.
- You want,
you want a guy at the
Treasury overseeing guns,
then pick the
biggest anti-gun guy.
You want somebody
looking at civil rights?
Well pick a woman who
hates white people
and goes on and on about
white people and so forth.
- Mark we got a gay guy
doing transportation.
Come on, that's qualification
enough isn't it?
Come on.
- Look there's two departments
they always give to guys
they don't care about.
Transportation and
HUD, so I wouldn't.
But here's the thing.
I think he's told them
who he wants to be
and what he wants to do.
I don't think he's there
working in the weeds
on all this stuff.
I think they're
giving him this stuff
and he's happy to sign it.
I think he's there over legacy.
He wants to create a
legacy for himself.
And he'll do almost
anything to do it
and that's what he's doing
and he's also by the way,
we haven't touched on it.
He's creating enormous
dangers overseas.
He's always been an incompetent
when it comes to that
and other things.
He sat on the Foreign
Affairs Committee,
sat on the Judiciary Committee,
two of the important committees
and he's been so wrong so often
that I am very worried
that before he goes
we're gonna be in
some kind of war.
If not with China, with Russia.
I think Iran's gonna
have nuclear warheads.
I think this world's gonna be
an absolute disaster and mess
because of him and because
of the people he's appointed.
So this is a very serious time.
- Indeed it is.
All right, let's shift.
I could do, I could
actually just do history.
Even getting away from politics,
I could do history with
you for hours but let's.
- Happy to do.
- Let's shift a little bit
from some of this because
I wanna talk about
the big tech portion
of all of this
because you've been
very outspoken but
not only outspoken,
you actually put your
money where your mouth is
in that you are not
on Twitter anymore.
You actually tweeted out,
I'll read it for everybody.
We'll put the Tweet up.
On January 8th, you wrote,
"I have suspended my
own Twitter account
"in protest against
Twitter's fascism.
"I ask all my followers
to join me now
"on Parler and Rumble."
Obviously a couple days later,
Parler's servers were blown up.
They are now back, at least
on the App Store temporarily.
But you're not happy about this.
You are weary of
centralized power,
whether it comes from the
government or from big tech.
I left Facebook
and I left Twitter
but I spent six weeks
telling everybody on Facebook
and Twitter I'm leaving
at the end of the year.
Here's where you can find me.
So I wasn't foolish
enough to cut my throat
and to do Facebook
and Twitter favors
until I was ready to
do what I wanted to do.
- [Dave] Right.
- So we have over five million
followers on Parler now.
We're starting to
build up Rumble.
We have what, five,
600,000 over there.
I believe in entrepreneurship.
I thank goodness,
thank God that we have
these other platforms that
are willing to compete.
I am not going to
participate in the fascism
that is being demonstrated
by these oligarchs.
I'm just not gonna do it.
They started giving me the
scarlet letter over and over
and over again.
I go what are you doing?
While this third party, while
they pick the third parties,
they're left wing's third
parties, they're not.
I said you know what, I'm not
gonna participate in this.
You're stealing the data
from millions of people
who follow me and I'm
telling millions of people
to unfollow you.
Now some do and some don't
but they've come over
to these other platforms.
And I feel the position I'm in,
I can help some of
these other platforms.
I'm not an investor
in any of them.
Not that there'd be
anything wrong with it
but I'm not and I
tell my folks look,
this is what I was talking
badass when we opened the show.
You gotta put your money
where your mouth is.
We can't just talk
about these things.
I'm not opposed to other
people staying on there
because they need them
and they want them
and they wanna build up
what they, everybody's.
Like I said everybody
has their own role.
My role is, as I told you early.
Get the hell out of my face.
You're gonna start giving
me a scarlet letter,
every time you disagree with me,
I'm done with you
it's that simple.
- Yeah, so what do you think
the role of government is,
related to big tech?
This is where the libertarian
beliefs that I have
have been really
pushed to the end.
You know it always
comes down to okay,
so build your own
internet and it's like,
well what should
the government do?
I mean I don't think
government regulators
wandering into Google
are gonna do anything.
I've heard more
liberty-minded people
say well at the very
least, break 'em up,
use some anti-trust.
Generally I don't think
the force of government's
gonna do much good at all.
I mean is there anything that
you think can be done here?
- There's several things.
I don't know how effective but
it's worth trying in my view
and I think they're
principled things.
Number one, in 1996 as part of
the Communications
Act legislation
they got a special privilege
which should be taken away.
There's no reason why
they should have immunity
as a public platform
from lawsuits based on
what other people post and
based on what they post.
Nobody else gets
that except the media
and that was a perverse New
York versus Sullivan decision
in the 1960s.
- Yep.
- That's not in the
Constitution either.
- Yeah, are you worried though
if you took 230 away
from them that in essence
they would just start
censoring everybody
because they would say,
"Hey, whoa we're suddenly
liable for all this stuff."
So now it's actually going
to increase censorship
at some level.
- They'd also face
10,000 lawsuits
which have no hope
of winning right now.
So I think they'd have
to say you know what,
we either go out of business
or we let everybody on there
and that's their defense
when they go to court.
Your Honor, we can't keep
track of all this stuff.
Because that's the thing.
If you're gonna
act like you can,
then you have responsibility
on your hands.
If you say to the court,
"We can't keep track
of all of this.
"We are in effect a public forum
"and so we can't
possibly be responsible
"for all these things."
I think they'd have
a better shot at it.
My problem is this,
it's not free market.
Not only do they
get this protection,
they are an appendage
of the Democrat Party
and so they've made
this abundantly clear.
How do we know?
We know through their
censorship who they support
and who they don't.
We know what Zuckerberg
did with $400 million.
- Right.
- To help the Democrats
in Democrat areas
of the country.
Where they put money in grants,
gave them to front groups.
The front groups worked
with the local governments
to get out the vote.
- Mark, they fortified
the election.
That's what they told us.
- Yes.
- This was to fortify it.
- They fortified
their party and to me,
we can't pretend
that's not happening.
So much of our speech now
has to be funneled
through big tech.
I mean they invite us on
these sites since 1996,
people come on, their friend
did, they're followed.
They're stealing our data,
they're making billions and
billions of dollars from it
and they are
controlling our speech
and they're controlling
our speech because in 1996
they were given a pass.
And here's the other thing
being a libertarian and all.
There's a lot of things
that could grow out of this
that we can't possibly know
or even imagine right now.
So if they really wanna
be part of the marketplace
then they gotta play
with all the other boys
and girls out there who
don't have these protections.
And then let's see how they do
and maybe they'll
break up on their own
and maybe something'll
come and replace it.
Right now it's an
oligopoly with protection.
So there's no way to know.
So my attitude is, this isn't
an issue of free markets.
I'm not trying to spin this.
I've thought about it a lot.
These people are
denying us liberty.
Who are these people
and why are they doing
what they're doing?
So when you
politicize this thing
and you put ideology
in this thing,
and then you go around banning
people and censoring people
and as I say you know,
putting a scarlet
letter on these people.
That's a whole
different ballgame.
If they were honest and
fair about all these things,
I could care less.
But they're not and you know,
Prempa's on his group
were keeping track
of all these people
who are being hammered,
it's so obvious what's going on.
So my attitude is you got a
special protection, remove it.
Whatever happens happens.
Things can grow out of it,
entrepreneurs can develop out
of it and look even Parler.
They tried to destroy Parler
and they've even
threatened them now.
Apple says, "You
meet our standards
"or you're out of their store."
So they're blackmailing them,
I don't think we can have that.
- Yeah, I'll give you
another silver lining
that I've been telling
people about all this
which is that as these
companies go further woke,
go further left,
they're bringing in
these diversity and
inclusion departments
and in essence they're
gonna hire based on quotas
as opposed to hiring
the best engineers
and the best managers
and thus that over time
will also cause
them to collapse.
- You know, you would hope so
but that could be a
long time from now.
So you never know.
- I didn't say how
fast, I just said.
- Yeah, right.
- It's a little,
a little bit of a silver lining.
- You know what's interesting?
They know more about us
than we know about them.
They know everything about us.
They have access to
everything we've ever written
on their platforms.
Access to anything
we've ever purchased.
They share the information
with each other.
They have third
party data collectors
that do exactly the same thing.
1996, nobody imagined
such a thing.
So it's a different entity
now and I'm not one of these
who say, you know
we broke up Exxon,
or Standard Oil so we
have to break up these.
I'm one of those who says,
"If the antitrust
laws apply, use them.
"If the states need
to come up with laws
"like Ron DeSantis in Florida,
federalism, use them."
They've picked a fight with us.
We didn't pick a
fight with them,
it's like the rest of
these corporatists.
We are just going
about our business.
They're running around
putting labels on us
because the Democrat party
wants them to put labels on us
and that's exactly
what they're doing.
They picked this fight,
we didn't pick this fight.
We gotta fight back.
- When you see guys like Ron
DeSantis do the you know,
big tech bill that he
just signed or you know,
now he's signing this,
I forget exactly what
they're calling it.
But this basically, making
a stronger distinction
between protesting and rioting.
He's doing a bunch of bills
that I think you know,
for sane people
sort of make sense.
That must sort of make
you feel validated in oh,
federalism does kind of
work and in a weird way,
the crazier that Biden and
the federal government gets,
it actually is bringing some
of the states back to the roots
and back to the way
it was supposed to be.
- That's exactly
right and you know,
I'm one of the early advocates
of convention of states.
This is a movement
to use Article Five
of the Constitution,
the Second Amendment process
to get our Constitution back.
The Constitution has been
amended over and over
and over again
through the backdoor.
Through court decisions,
through legislation,
through regulations.
It's being shredded
and that would include
the Bill of Rights and
separation of powers.
These are our protections
and so I've been saying,
I wrote a whole book on it,
"The Liberty Amendments",
originally I was against it.
And then I said wait a minute,
as I study it more, the
framers were for it.
That's why it's in
the Constitution
and the states signed off on
it, that's why it's there.
So I've been arguing
that we already live
in a Constitutional convention
where the left controls
what the Constitution
says over and over again
and is changing it.
And I've heard a lot of,
some objections to it
where people say,
"Well if you have a convention,
anything can happen."
They don't understand
the process.
No, anything can't happen.
It's like a, first of all
you have to have 34 states
sign off on it, legislatures.
That's not easy, we
have 14 right now.
Then you need 38
states to ratify.
So it's not like somebody's
gonna sneak something through
or anything like that or you
can have a Rump convention.
And not only that, under the
rules as we've studied this,
it has to be focused on a
few issues and the states,
the state legislatures,
not even the Governor
send the delegates.
And that fire alarm was
there and it was put there
by George Mason.
Two days before the end of
the Constitutional Convention.
He said and I paraphrase
but accurately,
"What do we do if Congress
becomes oppressive?
"The only out for the
states is a revolution.
"We've gotta provide something."
And so this was
what was proposed.
This state convention process.
Madison was originally
hostile to it
but then he embraced it.
You know when he embraced it?
He embraced it when states
started to nullify laws.
He embraced it when
states were thinking
of breaking off before
they actually did
and he pointed to
that and he said,
"Rather than destroy
the Union, look at this.
"We have Article Five.
"You guys, we can
get back together.
"It's just the states
having a meeting.
"We can get back together,
have a discussion on what it is
"we wanna change rather burning
down the whole Republic."
So in a letter in particular,
he had embraced
what he had opposed
as a way of trying to stave off
the disintegration of the Union.
So it's very important,
I don't know how much
luck we're gonna have
but I told you before.
Every front, we gotta
confront our friends.
- Yeah, so it's interesting.
Because we have these
options in front of us
to save some of this stuff.
But you know, look I'm here
in LA, I'm in California.
It is beyond imagination,
governed the wrong way
and hopefully we're
gonna recall Newsom
but knowing this state
we'll bring in someone
who's even worse.
But what do you do in a case
because you said disintegration
which is a phrase our
friend Ben Shapiro uses.
What do you in the case if okay,
California just keeps
going off the deep end,
keeps spending, keeps
doing everything wrong.
Then the good people of Texas,
the good people of Florida in
particular who vote properly,
have balanced budgets,
don't have income tax,
make sensible laws
related to policing
and all of the
rest of the stuff.
I could see them all
becoming extremely resentful
of having to bail out
those loony Californians
every now and again.
I cannot believe this is the
position I find myself in
at this point you know?
Relative to five years
ago but I get it now.
- The more that civil
society collapses,
the more the Constitution frays.
And so I worry
about these things.
I mean, the left
is pushing so hard.
Their foot is so far
down on the gas pedal,
there's gonna be
reaction one day.
I don't know what it's gonna be.
I don't know how
it's going to be.
I'm sure it's not
gonna be pretty
but people are gonna say,
"All right, to hell with
this law abiding stuff.
"To hell with this comedy stuff.
"To hell with this
civil society.
"They're destroying my schools,
"they're destroying
my kid's education,
"they're destroying my
job with open borders.
"Representative
government is a joke,
"they're taking half of my
income, I've had enough."
I don't know if that'll cause
states to break away again,
I don't know what the role
of law enforcement will be
and the, I don't know.
But I am deeply concerned that
the Democrats have no idea
how many fuses they're
lighting with their official
and unofficial relationship
with these Marxist entities,
including within
their own ranks.
So it's very concerning,
you're gonna have the
law of the jungle.
You lose the civil
society, that's it.
You talk about California.
You know I lived in
California very briefly
and the Governor was Pete
Wilson and you had Deukmejian
and of course you
had Ronald Reagan.
Those guys couldn't
get elected today
if their lives depended on it.
I remember George H.W.
Bush won California
when he ran for President on
Reagan's coattails and I also,
this isn't that long ago.
And I also remember
experts, so called saying,
it's gonna be a long
time until the Democrats
can win back the presidency
and they would show,
they can't win California,
they can't win Texas,
they can't win Florida,
they can't win.
So they can't win, so
what do the Democrats do?
Okay, we're gonna open
the spigot, no border.
We're gonna change this state
and what Pelosi from San
Francisco wants to do
is take California and
apply it to the entirety
of the rest of the state.
That's where she gets her
mindset, you know that.
Whether it's connection laws.
- That's literally what
she's saying,
you're not making that up.
- Yes.
- I mean that's what
she's telling us.
- And if they do
that, it's over.
We can't win,
and you know what?
- How do you?
- One party rule is a
very dangerous thing.
It's a dangerous thing
because people don't like it.
- So as somebody
that's been doing this
for a couple decades
longer than I,
how do you stay
sane throughou this?
'Cause I think we're also
watching so many people become
and there's many reasons for it
relative to lockdowns
and losing their jobs
and the general
disarray and chaos
but just people are depressed.
You know when I
do my daily show,
I always make a point of
trying to not be alarmist,
not be hysterical, end
on a positive note.
Tell them that this
isn't everything
but in a weird way right now
it's starting to become
everything even though we don't,
you know our salvation
is not through politics
and yet it's at our doorstep.
How have you managed to
kind of not go bananas
as someone that's
been warning about it
and then it still keeps coming?
- Well some people think I have,
who knows?
- Yeah.
- But that said, sometimes
I gotta walk away from it.
I'm almost done a
book I'm writing on,
it's very difficult
and I say to my wife,
I gotta step away from
this for two days.
It's just too depressing.
I, when I do my radio show I
wear my emotions on my sleeve.
Why do you yell, why are you
passionate, why are you this?
I said, "Well 'cause
I don't work for NPR,
"I'm a real human being.
"You know I do what I do."
- Right.
- But it is difficult
but people need to
find solace in family.
They need to, one
of the things I do.
You know they say misery
loves company, it's so true.
I think about those
men who fought
at the Revolutionary War
and how they suffered.
And I think about things
that other human beings
have gone through like the
Holocaust or World War Two,
the Battle of the
Bulge or D-Day.
Or the Korean War which
was a horrific war
that never gets talked about.
Or the Vietnam War, I
think about these things
that other human beings
have gone through
and they've gone through a
hell of a lot more than I have.
And so that helps
me mentally focus.
It also helps me
fight because I say
if these people are gonna
put their lives on the line
or if they're gonna die,
and their ancestors have to
speak up on their behalf,
then we have to do
something more than whine
and complain about these things.
Look at this country, this
is such a fabulous country.
It's such a diverse country.
You know I've talked
to so many people,
I've interviewed so many people
and Shelby Steele in particular,
something he said to me just
rings every day so true.
You're free.
You are free.
Do whatever you wanna
do with your life,
nobody's stopping you except you
and you don't know what
to do with your freedom.
You're free.
Now in how many countries
can you say that?
Very few.
And when you look at how
we send our men and women
off to war to defend people
who look differently than us,
who have different
religions than us.
In some hellhole somewhere,
for whatever the reason is
and then you call Americans
systemically racist?
This is blasphemy,
this is appalling.
When you look at this country
where we have the highest
rate of interracial marriage
in our history, over 20%.
When you look at the diversity
in our police forces,
the diversity in our military,
the diversity in our
public figures and acting
and so forth and so on.
When you look at millionaires
and billionaires of all colors
the idea that this country
is systemically racist,
we embrace a capitalist system.
The capitalist system
is incapable of racism.
It's literally
incapable of racism.
I give this example,
let's say I go to a diner.
Let's say somebody else goes
to a diner and they're a bigot.
And they get eggs and bacon
and milk and whatever it is.
They don't know who, who
owned that chicken farm.
Could've been a Black family.
They don't know where that bacon
came from, they don't know.
So he may be a bigot but
capitalism is not bigoted
and capitalism and
liberty go hand in hand.
It doesn't mean you can't
have capitalism and tyranny.
Like you have quasi-capitalism
and heavy handed
tyranny in China.
But for liberty, you
have to have capitalism.
This is very, very
important to understand.
So when there's an
attack on capitalism
it's really an attack on
private property rights,
liberty, your intellectual
and physical labor.
It is an attack on you.
So I look at this country
and I say to myself,
"These people who keep
calling it systemically."
There's really two kind
of people who do this.
It is the, the self anointed
or self proclaimed elite
or it's the, or it's the
Marxist ideologue in the street.
The vast majority of
people in this country,
I don't care if they're Black
or brown or they're what.
They're not pining for Marxism.
- No.
- They're not pining
to eliminate the cops.
They don't hate the
United States military.
So that is a positive.
Just think that most of the
people, we can get to them,
we can explain things to them.
I think most of them
will still be with us.
- I think that was
Mark Levin's opus.
You took us out beautifully.
I'm gonna ask you
to stick around,
so we're gonna do one thing
for my Locals exclusive.
I'm gonna ask you what
Mark Levin does for fun.
So I'm gonna let you think
about that for about 10 seconds.
I'm gonna thank ya
for doing the show.
We're gonna link to all your,
everyone knows where
you are and who you are
and all that good stuff
but we're gonna link
to all that below
and I just wanna tell ya,
it's really an
honor and a pleasure
and I hope we can this in
person one of these days.
- That would be great and the
honor and pleasure is mine.
You were absolutely
terrific, thank you.
- Thank you.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist
and if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlist all right over here
and to get notified
of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.